-Now, Halle and I are about
to face off in a game of
"Box of Lies."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Here's how it works.
Upstage are a bunch
of boxes containing objects
neither of us have seen before.
Taking turns, we're going
to select a box and open it
on our side of the table, out of
the view of the other person.
You remove the object
from the box,
show it to the audience,
our great audience,
then you look
at your opponent...
[ Cheers and applause ]
...and you tell them
what's in your box.
Then, they have to guess
if you're lying
or telling the truth.
We'll play three rounds.
Halle, why don't you go
pick the first box.
[ Audience yelling ]
Yeah, they can help you,
they can help you.
[ Audience yelling ]
Three, interesting.
-Three -- Oh, it's heavy.
-Oh, yeah, right,
it's really heavy.
Please, you're holding it
with one hand.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, my God.
Nice try, already.
That's a hint!
Ha ha, he he.
[ Laughter ]
Okay, good.
All right.
-Oh, shoot.
[ Laughing ]
[ Light laughter ]
Oh.
-I don't know if you --
If you're lying --
I don't know what's happening.
Already, already, already.
-It's -- it's a stuffed animal
of some sort...
-Okay.
With a -- like, a snake
wrapped around it.
With things on its head.
[ Laughter ]
-Now, this is not my first time
I've played this game.
"It's a stuffed animal
of some sort"?
Like, you don't know what
stuffed animal it is?
-You have to ask that.
-Now, what is it,
like a Hatchimal?
-No, it's an elephant.
-Or is it like a bear?
An elephant with a snake
wrapped around its head,
and things coming out of
the elephant or the snake?
-The elephant.
[ Light laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I will say, Halle Berry, you...
[ Drumroll ]
[ Light laughter ]
You're telling the truth!
[ Horn blows ]
-[ Screams ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Oh, my gosh.
I knew it,
I knew you were lying!
[ Laughing ] Oh, my God.
I knew you were lying.
Why did I -- I over thought --
I over thought it.
-[ Imitating horn ]
♪ Waa, waa, waa ♪
-Oh, my God. Get a life.
[ Laughter ]
All right, what number?
What number, I'm up.
[ Audience yelling ]
Someone said ten.
There is no ten!
Five?
[ Audience yelling ]
[ Grunting ]
[ Light laughter ]
Okay, here we go.
Okay.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers ]
All right.
I think I'm just going to have
to tell you the truth
on this one, I really do.
[ Laughter ]
I just -- I don't think
I can make this one up.
-It's fine.
-This is just a --
It's like a pencil sharpener
type of thing where --
Where you put the pencils,
or whatever, you put a --
You put a pretzel stick.
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughing ] In a dude's mouth.
And it sharpens your pencil.
-Sharpens your pencil?
-Yeah. Or yeah --
I think it looks like that,
it looks like some type of
pencil sharpener, yeah.
-In a dude's mouth?
-You put, like, a pretzel in
a dude's mouth and then a...
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughing ] You call --
You call it a day after that.
-So, is there a mouth on there?
-Yeah.
-Yeah, there's a mouth on there?
[ Laughter ]
-Is there a dude on there,
like a fake dude?
-Yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Sure.
-Okay, I think...
[ Drumroll ]
...you're telling the truth.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughing ]
[ Band plays ]
-How could I even lie?
After I saw this,
how could I make up
a lie about that?
It's the most insane thing
I ever seen in my life.
I'm so -- It feels so weird
to have to show that to you.
I'm sorry.
Halle, let's do one more round.
[ Cheers ]
This is worth 10,000 points!
Halle, you're up, you're up.
Any number.
-Okay.
[ Audience yelling ]
-This is aggressive --
aggressive yelling.
That was an aggressive four.
"Pick four"!
[ Light laughter ]
-Oh, you might see that.
That's too high.
-Hm.
-I'm going to put this one back.
[ Applause ]
-Oh, see?
I know a magic trick
when I see one.
Something just happened.
-Oh, [ bleep ].
[ Laughter ]
This has got
a lot of characters.
-Okay, a lot of
characters involved.
-A lot of characters involved.
Awesome dry cleaning.
-And what do you mean,
"dry cleaning"?
What's that mean?
-I don't know.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my goodness.
I don't even want
to hear anymore.
I think I can make my decision.
This is -- 'Cause you're good.
[ Drumroll ]
You lie!
[ Audience groans ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Horn blows ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
She's the best right there,
Halle Berry, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you for doing that.
You're good.
You are fantastic.
That's why she wins
Academy Awards!